bonjour giuseppe bettoni merci beaucoup
d'être en direct ce matin avec nous sur
rt france cela faisait près de dix ans
qu'un président italien n'était pas reçu
en visite d'état en france
comment est-ce que c'est perçu à rome
c'est un élément très important parce
que au contraire de ce que beaucoup de
gens pensent
c'est à dire que le petit banc n'a pas
beaucoup de pouvoirs à l'état il n'y a
pas beaucoup de rôles as
constitutionnellement il n'a pas
beaucoup de pouvoir
mais d'un point de vue la sitution
c'était instruction très importante pour
nous tous en italie est donc cette
rencontre est la plus importante
rencontre qui pourrait y être et c'est
un élément très important parce que
c'est vrai
vous l'avez bien expliqué ont bien d'une
décennie qu'on ne comprend même pas
pourquoi notre nos relations ont été
très rude mise à dure épreuve par des
éléments disons politiques
institutionnels mais aussi beaucoup par
des éléments de certains personnes
individuelles de certains personnages de
la république donc c'est vrai que la
difficulté est importante d'un compte en
italie comment dire n'a pas énormément
changé les agendas et l'intérêt des gens
mais parce qu'on est au mois de juillet
en été c'est vrai que beaucoup de gens
un peu la tête ailleurs mais tous les
journaux en parlent avec comme un
élément très important et du lignon
l'intérêt alors élément important est ce
que c'est un élément positif c'est vrai
que la dernière visite faisait remonter
à 2012 avec giorgio napolitano qui était
venu en france
quand vous dites que c'est ces tensions
sont le fait de personnes
il s'agit de matteo salvini évidemment
c'est plus une brouille de personnes que
une brouille due
des éléments contextuels avéré comme la
question de l'immigration est ce que
tout ça c'est réglé selon vous alors que
c'est pas tout régler et c'est pas que
par rapport à des sciences de personnes
attention c'est lisant que la question
salle vide et la question de di maio
condé d'un contre les jets les jeunes
c'est une comment dire des accidents
assez grave ça il faut quand même le
dire mais qui concernait vraiment la
personnalité politique c'est de
personnes dont olivier mallet encore
aujourd'hui le ministre des affaires
étrangères il faut pas non plus oublier
alors qu' il y avait quand même des
éléments importants quand vous parliez
de red earth où certaines entreprises
italiennes
c'est qu'il partit à l'élément pourtant
la question migratoire est sans aucun
doute la question la plus importante
parce que la honte vraiment on s'est
senti lâché par la france mais surtout
par toute l'europe
cette question qui a mis en difficulté
et nommément un pays l'italie et qui
aurait dû conserver tout perdre ça
brouille et je pense si vous voulez
qu'on a assisté en à une erreur
importante mais deux pays
ça c'est la démonstration que on est des
pays souverains mais si on ne travaille
pas ensemble ce parlons tout le temps
lorsqu'on fait du business lorsqu'on
fait des ententes avec l'allemagne on en
oublie qu'il ya de l'autre côté à notre
acteur politique c'est une grosse erreur
la libye en est un exemple avoir agi en
libye sont même pas consulté l'italie
pour des rencontres faites à paris je
trouve ça tout à fait dans la liberté de
l'autorité de la profession mais
probablement en délicats si vous mettez
tous ces types d'éléments ensemble ça
fait la période qu'on a eu et je ne
pense pas que ça a été dans l'intérêt ni
de la france ni de l'italie donc c'est
pour cette raison que ma part elle a
aujourd'hui est à paris je pense plus
que pour combler presque des années
d'absence d'un président de la
république italienne à france c'est
vraiment un moment bien choisi avec un
but très précis oui parce qu'il ya cette
question migratoire vous l'avez dit
qu'ils restent en suspens d'autant que
les confinements
respectives sont terminées ce qui va
faire un appel d'air a priori pour pour
ces migrants
est ce que paris coopèrent davantage
avec l'italie pour l'aider justement à
résoudre à résoudre cette question au
niveau européen
alors c'est plutôt au niveau européen
pascal niveau concret la chose n'a pas
énormément changé on craint le pire
c'est à dire le pire c'est qu'en gros
moyens sont débordés et aujourd'hui
personne en italie a plus le plaisir ou
la différence de voir des dizaines de
gens mourir au large des côtes de ton
pays c'est quelque chose de difficile à
avoir à chaque fois et ça devient un
accident politique interne très
important ça secoue si vous voulez la
cohésion du pays tout entier
alors les moyens ça reste grosso modo
les mêmes essais des erreurs mais un
niveau européen vous avez raison la
france et non seulement la france
certains pays commencent à à concrétiser
avec des actions avec une présence
politique avec un soutien précis à
niveau politique
après il faudra concrétiser ça avec des
actions concrètes c'est à dire comme on
distribue les réfugiés dans les
différentes parties comment on paye
certaines choses parce qu'on ne peut pas
toujours délégué à la libye ou à la
turquie ce type de interdit mais
problème il faut vraiment les accueillir
ou du moins gérer ce qui arrive qu'un
des saignements dit manière collective
et audi il ya un traité de coopération
qui traîne depuis 2018 est ce que il est
en bonne voie d'être enfin signé selon
vous il y a des intérêts évidemment
économique très important entre les deux
pays
c'est les intérêts économiques
aujourd'hui on négocie évidemment parce
que sinon le traité serait déjà signé en
même temps je pense que si on le signale
un pas maintenant je ne sais pas quand
on va le signer donc sans doute c'est un
élément important
on va le signer je l'espère un sans
doute au moins et mais en même temps il
faudra encore définir certains rapports
les rapports économiques d
au pays sont toujours faits d'une
manière telle individuel on a toujours
cette logique de ne pas renoncer à des
intérêts qui sont ou à l'intérêt pour la
france ou un intérêt pour l'italie mais
c'est un événement que je considère
comme un passage nouveau parce que ça va
vraiment donner convenir de la
concrétise de la concrétisation en aura
fort dans les années à venir
c'est à dire avoir un rapport
définitivement comme celui que la france
avec l'allemagne et il aura aussi
définitivement avec l'italie on pourra
peut-être évité d'avoir encore des
accidents comme on les a eus dans les
années 2000 19 merci beaucoup
tu es fait détoner une dernière question
comment va le pape ce matin bah écoute
et apparemment il va nettement mieux il
a parfaitement bien réagi à ce
l'intervention chirurgicale
ça rassure beaucoup de monde parce que
c'était assez inattendu c'est un
problème relatif à gérer la pandémie
chirurgicale mais apparemment énergique
très très bien la presse en parle
régulièrement il a des communes qui
tient par donc ça me dit que ça va merci
beaucoup pour ces précisions et merci
d'avoir répondu à nos questions ce matin
en direct de rome dans la matinale
berthet france